speaking of Trump and policy Donald
Trump now in the midst of flip-flop
after flip-flop on his deportation force
and his policy on undocumented
immigration has announced he is going to
give a major speech tomorrow night
wednesday night in the back story of
this entire thing is that the
deportation the forced deportation at
our expense of 11 million undocumented
immigrants from the united states was
sort of the baseline around which Trump
built his campaign it was about Mexico
sending us the rapists it was about
banning Muslims and it was about
forcefully deporting all undocumented
immigrants in the u.s. cut to last week
after 15 months of this repetitive
statement that everybody's getting
deported and Trump started testing or
going potentially in a different
direction saying well we're gonna focus
on really the criminal undocumented
immigrants were not necessarily going to
just start kicking every up everybody
out we need to have empathy we need to
sort of do exactly what it is that
President Barack Obama has been doing
although he didn't exactly say that most
recently uh and that didn't really go
well this backfired completely because
many people on the right many Republican
voters saw this for what it is which is
partial amnesty something that they are
very much against Trump tried to
distinguish between so-called violent
criminals who are undocumented in the US
and those who are here illegally and
that is their only crime and the problem
for Trump is that many of the hardline
Republicans don't see a difference for
them if you're here illegally that is as
important of a crime as if you are here
illegally and assaulted someone or
robbed a bank or killed someone or
whatever so then Donald Trump at the
flip-flop again at a rally over the
weekend strengthening the language again
and saying we are going to deport people
people are going to go out etcetera
etcetera now this is a huge mess and
Donald Trump apparently is going to try
to fix it one more time he tweeted
yesterday I will be making a major
speech
on illegal immigration on Wednesday in
the great state of Arizona big crowds
looking for a larger venue this is going
to be pretty interesting because Trump
hasn't spoken in detail about a single
issue for this entire campaign that he's
been running and it hasn't seemed to
matter because it's not clear that
voters actually expect Donald Trump to
give any firm policies they seem really
comfortable with the idea that hey Trump
as a general idea and he has these
general principles bad people out we
need a border we need a country help sir
figure out the details later on in one
perfect example I'll put up on the
screen for you from a recent NPR article
that actually talked to a Nevada voter
named Judy Callahan who who spoke to
sarah mccammon and said listen not
everything Trump says is true I mean
it's not true like it's in concrete he
said he would stop the border flow he
would build some kind of wall and he
would work on the people that are here
that's all there is the rest is kind of
fluff other people also said well we
assume that what Trump says is just a
starting point for a negotiation it's
not necessarily set in stone and this
goes to the brilliance I've criticized
so many aspects of what Trump has done
from a political strategy perspective
Jason right I've said this is bad
strategy this is not going to win votes
but I've also praised this taking every
position and everything is sort of
negotiable and really what it what it's
about is I'm a good manager and I'll
bringing good people which he hasn't
done but it is actually working I
predicted that it's great to actually
take every position at some point
because everybody can find a position
they like on any particular issue if you
want the aggressive force deportation of
11 million people he has said that if
you want deporting just the really bad
ones and having more empathy he's been
on record as saying that as well and I
think strategically for the
low-information Trump voter it's
brilliant strategy yeah he's treating
this campaign as a giant focus group
where he goes to every single segment of
the population tells them exactly what
they want to hear and then retracts it
later except
no one's hearing the retractions and
they're so I'm excited for this he's
gonna actually lay out a concrete plan
well maybe maybe but so we'll see if he
will actually stick to any of these or
is he going completely new is it is copy
and paste brock obama's immigration plan
yeah we might we might see something
we've never we Trump seems to have taken
every position on this issue already we
might still see a new position that he
can concoct between now and tomorrow
night speech last thought on this and I
do have to move on I don't think any of
this is to court Hispanic voters in the
same way that none of the so-called
black outreach that backfired is to
court black voters this is all to appeal
to moderate white voters who were very
skeptical about Trump I've talked about
how people of all ages but particularly
Millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is zip car which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zipcard each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between 1100 and 1,600
pounds per year for our audience zipcar
is offering $25 a free driving credit if
you sign up at joined zipcar dot-com
slash david support our show reduce your
carbon emissions and you're spending on
cars sign up at join zipcar dot-com
slash david